The Windsor framework is first and
foremost for the people families
communities and businesses of Northern
Ireland that's who we should have
uppermost in our mind and because of
this Windsor framework we can absolutely
correct the issues that were there with
the protocol we can ensure Northern
Ireland's place in our Union ensure that
Northern Ireland's people and
institutions have sovereignty and means
we can now look forward to a better and
brighter future for Northern Ireland
that's who it's about it's about the
people of Northern Ireland and it
represents a very good way forward for
them
let's go live to Westminster and our
political correspondent Liz Bates Liz so
is all of this Westminster framework a
big political win for him or or because
it's not got storm and back up and
running is it is it a leap to say that
um well in many ways the Windsor
framework it has been a huge success for
Rishi sunai because in a really short
period of time he managed to solve some
what seemed like intractable problems in
Northern Ireland that were caused by
brexit he managed to charm EU leaders he
got a number of uh success
um a number of concessions uh that
previous Prime Ministers had failed uh
to get he was backed by the majority in
the end of his party and the labor party
backed The Windsor framework as well but
what we saw last week when it came to
part of the Windsor framework called the
Storm at break which was voted on in the
House of Commons the dup in the end the
government thought they had met all
their tests and had provided them with
the safeguards on sovereignty in
Northern Ireland within that stomach
break that they needed but in the end
the dup rejected that and that does
cause a serious problem for the Prime
Minister because although the Windsor
framework was designed to do many things
to sort out those political and economic
problems that being caused by the
Northern Ireland protocol one of the big
wins was supposed to be getting the dup
on side and getting storm and sitting
again because as you said the up have
been boycotting someone and they say
that is because of the problems that
were caused with the Northern Ireland
protocols so at this point those issues
with stormant the problems the political
problems with the dup remain unresolved